hey Steve hey Michelle I'm 35. never
been married no kids and I'm waiting on
my person I've never online dated all
right let me just speed this up a little
bit she's waiting on her person okay so
let's see what she's got here
it hinged tendered bumbled mingled and
don't plan to because I just don't have
the time
I will tell you I have high expectations
for myself
and I will have them for that man that
comes alongside me and wants to run this
life race admittedly I am quite
independent and an alpha female but not
like the ball break here we go she's an
alpha female but then she's about to
tell you not like the ball breaking kind
I'm sure she's not breaking domineering
type I'm a woman of service I love
people and
and I get spread quite thin and go all
kinds of directions in my city
but now I'm going to pause it here this
is about 44 seconds I was I was looking
for this video in my saved uh shelf last
night when I because I usually create my
unplugged Alpha podcasts Sundays
um and then I'll promote it and you know
do the event that way so I'm sort of
playing this through to like okay what
am I going to title this video my
girlfriend's in the kitchen she's making
sushi like she's got this new uh
Obsession for making fresh sushi awesome
love it I like to eat she likes to cook
perfect you know what she says while I'm
playing this out 44 seconds and she goes
yeah but can you make sushi [ __ ]
this like this is what a good woman
understands take care of a guy feed him
right compliment his life he's he's
doing work he's doing things so while
he's doing that I'm gonna make food for
him this is what you get on the other
side of the scale you know with the uh
queendom sort of thing let's carry on
I just need that man who can literally
just be there right alongside me so
Steve
do you think my independent alpha female
mentality comes off too strong yes it's
gross good question have you been in
long-term relationships I have I've been
in three and all all less than about a
year and a half and I call it off
actually a wedding as well and the guys
were incredible just not the ones I want
to spend my life with like life
responsibility issues you an alpha woman
extremely independent but you want a man
that's more alpha male than you are and
you want to know if he's out there
well yeah like the faith-filled you know
I need like a Scottie Pippen to my MJ
like I'm MJ you know like Michael Jordan
so
if you're not familiar with basket and
I'm not a big sports fan I just happen
to know this because I've gone through
Tim s Grover's Books uh Relentless and
winning and he worked very closely with
these athletes so Michael Jordan was
basically the number one athlete Scottie
pipp so she's basically saying
I'm Michael Jordan and I want a sidekick
like Scottie Pippen no
we're going to get into what she does
for a living but I'm just gonna leak it
here for you she's a she she's a teacher
she's a principal for a school
um and she's she's hoping to land a
world-class athlete that's better than
her let's keep going
to talk to me
like come along
and
anybody
no ain't no mountain to do that you
Michael Jordan
to be your sky
what what what
yeah what strong independent Mo alpha
male Union met that's fitting to be the
Scotty and let you be the Michael Jordan
I mean I can be the Scotty the Rodman
but I mean is the Michael Jordan out
there that's yeah
but but let me say this though
I don't think the problem is you've had
three long-term relationships from three
great guys most people can't say that
right
I think it's you okay okay so I have
when I say have high expectations
they're from like here to heaven so I
wake up read devotion read Bible I have
a master's degree then I have a small
volunteer and non-pro like strictly
volunteer and non-profit so I'm quite
busy and a principal of a middle school
okay so quite busy
non-profit a degree and a principal of a
middle school
your average at best okay like any
dating app is filled with like hundreds
of these within any dating radius of any
guy right and
let's be honest I mean
she's not a 10.
yeah so like I
and I can make time for a man
I mean I cook I will go out get dolled
up I can do it okay but I just need
someone that can support me in all the
endeavors
she wants a kickstand she wants a guy to
support her endeavors
she wants an equal that's going to like
give up his [ __ ] to support her and like
the thing that these that these women
don't understand these these these
queenies or whatever you know they're
calling themselves now
there's only one driver's seat in a car
and that's handled by the driver when
I'm in a car I'm the one driving my gal
is in the passenger seat she's happy
being there I'm happy where I'm at and
that works out but when you have two
people pulling on the steering wheel
trying to direct things all the time
this is where [ __ ] gets complicated and
the problem is is the only guys that
these gals can get
are lower quality and they're not that
attracted to them over the long-term
basis so like she said I've been in
three long-term relationships they
didn't work out they lasted a year year
and a half they were all great guys you
know it's always the same lyrics there's
just a great guy just a great guy but I
didn't want to marry him or I didn't
want to have his children or whatever
it's because she wants better
but the better guys aren't going to
abandon their Life Strategies putting a
dent in the universe chasing Excellence
to help a middle school teacher and be
her kickstand that's not how it works
these women don't seem to understand
that but they've been lied to by Society
by culture and said go get your degrees
go set up your non-profit go be kind to
animals go blah blah blah all these
things and frame it all in Mahogany and
put it on the wall and decorate your
house and put eat love pray everywhere
in the house in words and you will find
the right guy and these guys never come
along for the most part if they if they
do end up getting a dude she has to
settle she has to abandon a lot of her
must-have lists and gets usually a guy
that's for the most part just maybe on
par with her or slightly lower that's
what they get you inadvertently said you
want your Scotty to Yo which is really
what you meant but you had to fix it
after you cry away so so you had to
adjust and you said well I'll be to rob
me but not really though and there's
nothing wrong with you having what you
have doing what you do and wanting what
you want I never asked a woman to dumb
it down if you have a high expectations
of yourself and your life you should go
and do it and don't stop what you're
doing just for a man
you understand but not hear that preach
Steve You Preach Steve you tell us all
man we can be we can be and do it all I
understand this now what man has to come
along and be willing to fit into your
system that's hard to find because see
we got we come with issues
and if we can't be the man what makes up
could you guys imagine if I had a TV
show like this with an audience like
that
how long would that show last maybe like
a pilot episode
that's that's what the world needs man
it's some more cold hard truth oh man I
stroke that ego
that you have in high standards tell me
the type of man you're looking for just
tell me what that is
who is this right here this is my
incredible mother she's heard this
before well she and she wants grandkids
yeah oh and look the incredible mother
doesn't have a man beside her shocking
like yesterday yesterday but I keep
telling her to ask my brother
so
um let's get let's get back to those
qualities
by the way guys before you wipe up a
check take a look at her mom
okay if you want to see what you're
going to be getting later on down the
road
um so I like what you said everything
that I like that today I like no tell me
no no no no no no no I won't hear what
you are
I want you to tell me what you want in a
minute all right Faith Hill God first
okay smart and witty hang on let me
write all this [ __ ] down
let's get her list down for the ladies
all right
all right let's go
God-fearing man
so it can hold a good conversation okay
adventurous oh hang on it's got to be
witty too
adventurous
because she doesn't like boring because
you can do anything to a woman you want
except for bore her right he likes to
travel oh she let oh shocking she likes
to try another woman that likes to
travel
but does she travel on her own dime or
does she travel on his damn dime like
the rest of them for the most part
Family First Family First okay
secure with himself doesn't have to have
a lot of money just
secure and willing to support
their teammate
teammates teammates
team man we hates oh my God teammates
can you imagine being her teammate you
don't need a lot of money but I
guarantee you she won't pick you fellas
if you don't have at least what she's
got I don't know what a middle school
teacher makes in California I'm assuming
this is where they film it maybe 80 100
grand
oh sorry principal maybe 800 Grand
something like that so you'd have to
make at least that together so you got
to be God-fearing witty adventurous and
you know the funny part that I always
find about these God-fearing women now
she's had three other boyfriends for a
year and a half each so she's been with
at least three other guys we know it's a
lot more than that so how can you demand
a God-fearing man if you're not even
subscribed to your religious beliefs to
begin with and showing up as a virgin
yeah
that's truly what I've have I missed
anything mom yeah oh about 20 things
yeah you've missed I don't I still
haven't heard the type of man you want
oh you want like a like the even the
physical characters I'm not the type of
man you want a male type is you want a
man who is this way this way does this
feels this thinks that that's a type
maybe we're having trouble with finding
it because you don't know exactly what
it is
third received and let me tell you
something and you all that in a bag of
chips you everything okay so salsa and
he's just and he just finished lying to
this chick saying you're all that in a
bag of chips and then she adds on top of
it salsa
queso quesadilla man oh yeah I got it
all down in this
she thinks she's all that in a bag of
Doritos
I know
but you'd have had three men that are
locked in on that lot but then what you
kept wanting from them they didn't live
up to it and I wanted to live out my
dream too so not and you want to live
out your dream and I did so now I'm 35.
but see you can't drag everybody with
you on your dreams you don't want to go
so if if I want to help you lady because
you seem like you really want this
answer if I just knew what you wanted
if you knew what you wanted
you feel me I do I'm crying because I'm
I got it connected I get it see you're a
sweet person so here let me tell you
what you got going for you I think your
personality is Top Flight seem like a
fun person you know you seem sweet
you're not nasty or evil you got
beautiful personality you're pretty
you're nice looking lady you take care
of yourself and you seem to be so far to
have made yourself happy
now and yet she's standing there crying
all we need is for you to be willing to
do for someone else the same thing that
you expect them for do to do for you
instead of trying to find the person
that fits this you got to find out where
you fit too I think if you do that
that's it thanks to you there you go
problem solved all her woes are over
well done Steve good job
we've got that problem solved so you see
guys this is you know this is like you
know
this is what you're gonna get right this
is why ladies if you're watching this
this is probably why you're struggling
to deal with guys we don't give a [ __ ]
about your degree we don't care about
your pet collection we don't give a [ __ ]
about your Decor in your house and your
Eat Pray Love words that you stick in
random places
we don't care about any of that stuff
are you feminine are you agreeable can
you be a now if you're talking about
finding the kind of guy that she's
describing the handsome virtuous tall
successful competent captivating guy
like all of those traits that women
typically go for
that's what you got to be as a lady
right women don't share their pot of
gold with guys we know that we know that
okay you're if you're a guy and you're
dating a gal in her 30s like this and
you make around the same amount of money
or maybe a little bit less first thing
she's going to do is say I want a prenup
women don't share their pot of gold with
a guy it's just how it is get used to it
okay
ladies stop stop buying into all that
nonsense about
you know be a boss girl and I need my
Scotty to my MJ you know what I'm saying
Steve hey guys I really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out